you'd wake up just with those first
thoughts of the day would just oh God
I did have a
fear that I was gonna
[Music]
be one of the most recognizable
broadcasters she's become synonymous
with the Olympics football and rugby
I was very male dominated environment
and there certainly were people who
exhibited kind of machismo and there
were times where I felt like I was
trying to conform but it didn't make me
feel very good I wasn't happy
my dad was an assistant manager of
Bradford City when the fire there took
56 lives and we were all there at the
game that day
all day of my life really because there
is a before and there's an after and
that day is that day that really defined
not so many things for me can you still
remember that you get a phone call from
your mother about your brother it's a
day that I have relived so many times in
my mind I can't express how shocking
that is because he was fine you know in
my mind immediately created a narrative
that he had been run over or he had been
in a car accident and then very quickly
my mum started to tell me actually what
had happened
before this episode begins I just want
to say a huge thank you to all of our
new subscribers 74 of you that watch
this channel didn't subscribe before and
we're now down to about 71 so that helps
us in a number of ways that are quite
hard to explain but simply the bigger
the channel gets the bigger the guests
get so if you haven't yet subscribed to
the Diary of a CEO if I can have any
favors from you if you've ever watched
the show and enjoyed it it's just to
please hit the Subscribe button without
further Ado I'm Stephen Butler and this
is the Diary of a CEO I hope nobody's
listening but if you are then please
keep this yourself
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
to understand you and to understand the
trajectory of your life and how you've
ended up to be where you are today and
the passions you pursued the person you
became what do I need to understand
about your earliest context
I hope I've gone into that in my book
and I've tried to understand that myself
and one of the biggest compliments
somebody has paid me who's read the book
is somebody I work with really closely
and she just said to me I get so much
about you from some of the stories
you've told as as a child even and we
can all point to Big incidents that
happen in life but actually sometimes
it's just the small things that create
in your mind and urgency or they create
a desire or a passion that you know um
still Burns inside you and you wonder
where it came from
um so I think you probably would need to
understand a bit about the parenting
that I received and the context of our
family life and where when we moved
around and how our lives were predicated
by my dad's job and what he did and the
background that he had as well he was a
professional football player he was a
professional football player so that
means potentially moving house moving
City at the drop of a hat this was in
the 70s and 80s the days where you could
be transferred midweek you know it
wasn't the transfer window that we have
now so he would often upsticks and move
on and then a few months later we'd
follow what does that what does that do
to a child never really asked somebody
that question before when you're
constantly moving around as a kid is
there in hindsight any sort of character
change or psychological impact of for
better off or For Worse I think it has
uh there's a double-edged sword to it my
mum and it depends I guess on the other
person in the relationship my mum has
always been a very positive person so
she looked at these things for us as
Adventures you know she would say to me
and my siblings I'm going to move to
this place and it's going to be very
exciting and you've got to go to a new
school and it's a chance to meet new
people and so her sense of adventure
gave us a confidence and a sense that
you know it was going to be okay so that
was great but then what I realized
writing the book was that it probably
made me a bit flighty when it came to
friends when I was younger and I look
back at I was writing about a really
close friend I had when I was 13. I've
got no idea where she is now and I think
because the next time I had to move on
somewhere and at that point I was
actually staying within Leeds but I
probably was moving schools I'd got used
to going bye-bye and kind of moving on
to the next place so I was probably
experiencing a bit of self-preservation
you know not wanting to get too close
because we might be off soon so we'll
have a good time for now
were you a confident person when you
were you know let's say before your 18th
birthday would you describe yourself as
a confident person self-esteem and yeah
I would I think that is something that
as well that my husband and I talk about
this a lot the the greatest gift you can
give children is self-esteem I think and
he left school without self-esteem
because he was dyslexic and left without
any qualifications and it is his big
passion that kids should always have the
star within them found before they leave
school whatever that is you know
somebody needs to tell you you are good
at something before you're on your way
and um I I feel like I was incredibly
lucky because I left school with really
good self-esteem and I had a childhood
that was that gave me good self-esteem
you know and I believed that I could
achieve things and I could I could get
on in life and I think a lot of that was
my mum's positivity certainly but also
my dad's example of really hard work and
seeing him really graft and really
believe that you know what you put in
you got out and I think that's really
rewarding you know that is really that
makes you feel so good when you work
hard and that's the example that he he
said to us and I think that all creates
a confidence because and when I say
confidence is not misplaced in the sense
that you think everything you do is
going to be brilliant because you really
need to know that you're going to fail
at things obviously and that things are
going to go wrong and I could see that
with with both of them but I think a
belief that if it does go wrong it's
okay because you can move on so I feel
one of the biggest blessings I had as a
child was leaving school with confidence
thinking then about you saying your dad
it's still hard work
um kind of into by example I guess
because he was clearly someone that was
incredibly focused and
um focused on his career
it made me made me think about how we
often
don't get to learn how to take care of
ourselves from our parents in terms of
we learn how to to work hard and strive
but the sort of counterbalance to that
would be learning how to slow down and
learning how to
um make sure you're okay and I think
specifically when I talk to people when
you know on this show when they talk
about their fathers and their and the
generations that I've come before
there's often little understanding of
mental health or
um burnout or balance or all of these
kinds of things did you did you see the
symptoms of
that in your father did you see a lack
of sort of self-preservation or
self-care absolutely
um he
he came from a generation of men he came
from a well first let's go back he came
from a really tough working class estate
in Cardiff he was 15 years old when he
was plucked out of that and given an
opportunity to go to Leeds United and be
a footballer 15 years old he'd left his
home and he was living in digs with a
with a family who kind of put
footballers up and he was you know that
was a way out for him his dad had been a
Docker and he'd owned working Men's
Clubs and when I say owned he'd kind of
run a working man's club his mum had
four or five different jobs she was
doing night shift cleaning and he had
siblings who left school without
qualifications and did working class
Blue Collar jobs and so this was a big
opportunity and this wasn't the day
these weren't the days when the Premier
League was in existence but this was
still a you know a glamorous route
potentially and also a financially
secure as secure as she can be being a
sports person way out of the life that
he had and so that was an enormous
responsibility I think for him and he
this was a very a renowned hard odd kind
of team lead United was this team that
you know these players would renounced
being very hard on the pitch they were
you know kind of very brutal the way the
style of play and he's in that
environment as this little boy you know
I look at my son now who's 17 and I
think about what he would have been like
at 15 moving a few hundred miles away
from home and so already you're in you
know at that age you're having to build
up defenses and then he was you know
totally wasn't good enough and you know
had to keep working harder and and
eventually played there for 10 years and
was an international Captain for his
country so he did achieve incredible
things in his career but never stopped
you know it was relentless being a
footballer is Relentless being a sports
person is Relentless you're never going
to achieve Perfection you're always
looking for it so how do you feel
satisfied you know when do you actually
sit down and go that was really good and
I suppose there was a sense of him
always wanting you know keep going keep
going and then when you turn to
management which he did straight away
without a break and then he went through
he huge huge tragedy he was the
assistant manager of Bradford City when
the fire there took 56 lives and we were
all there at the game that day and he
went to almost every funeral in the
space of six weeks after that you know
he did all of this and never sat down
with anybody and took stock or had a
counselor or took a break from you know
from that relentlessness and so I think
I understand him a lot better now
through looking at his life through that
prism almost of seeing that and you
understand you know I talk in the book
about him drinking too much and using
that to self-medicate through his life
and to the point where it became you
know it's been a problem and he's been
hospitalized but of course now if he was
that Sports person now they'll be a
sports psychologist at the club you know
there'd be somebody saying let's have a
chat let's talk about what's what's
going on why you're feeling these these
levels of anxiety so
um it's it's definitely something that
I'm much better at and um but I think
that's also a product of the age that we
live in that we're all so much more
aware of the need to stop and the need
to process
when you when you look at his life
you've described a few of them there but
what what in hindsight now what are the
needs that you think were unmet in his
life and I asked that question because
I'm
I'm wondering how one avoids such an
outcome you talked about the importance
of connection not going home to a bunch
of strangers being closer to your family
are there any needs that you think went
unmet that you are making sure that your
son's life and your life are um full of
he was very my dad was always a very
emotional person so I don't feel like he
kept his emotions locked up you know he
would in front of us he was he would cry
you know he would watch something on TV
um a usually sport that would make him
teary so it wasn't as if he was this
hard person who didn't tell you he loved
you he told us he loved us but I feel
like as a professional in his job I feel
like it was it was probably very hard
for him to show any weakness outside of
the home and show any and when I say
weakness such a pejorative term because
actually it's not a weakness to say I
think I could be better if I just had
this bit of time here or I could speak
to somebody or I could you know
communicate better about how I'm feeling
about this and we are talking about a
very different era and um when it was
that it's not manly you know it's not
it's not manly to behave in that way and
we just wouldn't hear those terms now
even though some people still Harbor
those feelings perhaps they wouldn't say
that in public so I think if he had had
and he did have the opportunity when my
brother died and after Bradford to talk
to people but he resisted that you know
he didn't want to sit down and speak to
a counselor and I think that was
probably because of the historic kind of
experiences that he'd had you know it
just wasn't something that he felt
talking to people outside of the home he
was not comfortable it's that easy to to
teach to your kids that idea of sort of
expressing yourself and
turning to others for support
emotionally is it is it something that
you think about when you when you're
raising your children yeah we talk about
specifically we talk about it a lot and
we hope we lead by example as parents
but I'm more mindful of it with my son
because of the male kind of resistance
almost to to have that um open dialogue
but he is a very much a kind of he let's
wears his heartlessly likes to tell you
stuff and I think that's probably
because his dad is very much like that
so he sees his father being like that
and feels confident that he can he can
do that and I think once you do that as
a child and you realize the reception is
good and you're not going to be judged
or anybody think any less of you you're
more likely to come back and and do it
again so I think it is a lot about the
home and you know having the example of
somebody doing that in front of you is
really powerful and you're never with
your kids it's never a finished job
where you feel like oh yeah he's
somebody but I really do feel like he
knows he can talk to us about anything
and you can talk to other people and he
does you know bring his anxieties and
troubles home I think the key thing I'm
I find as a parent that you have to
remember especially when they kind of
turn 13 that age sometimes those things
to you seem quite trivial and you think
why are you bothering about that and
then you've got to remember what it's
like to be 13 and 14 and how huge those
things are and how big they were for you
and not just go that really doesn't
matter you know and actually it's really
important that you don't minimalize
their issues and their problems it's
okay for you because you've been through
so many different things and you know
it's going to be all right but they
don't know that right now so it's
important I think to to just always try
and take yourself back to that teenager
you've been through so many things and
many of those things I mean so many of
those things are in this book the first
half one of the most uh heart-wrenching
stories you tell us when you were 19
years old and you get a phone call from
your mother about your brother
Daniel
can you still remember that day clearly
oh absolutely and when I wrote that
chapter which turned out to be the first
chapter in the book because it was I
wrote it because I wanted to practice
writing to get myself into the rhythm of
writing the book not knowing where that
chapter would be and when I wrote it I
realized it had to be the start of the
book because it was the seminal day of
my life really because there is a before
and there's an after and that day is
that day that really defined so many
things for me and when I sat down to
write I took myself kind of right back
into that day I could I could almost
smell the air you know because it was a
bank holiday Monday I was living in a
small flat in earlsfield in London and
everybody's windows were open because it
was a lovely day and people were
barbecuing in their little Gardens and I
could smell the coals and I could feel
the the air coming through the windows
almost and I was just taken right back
into that moment the light everything
that came through the window when I sat
on the bed I can see the duvet cover I
can you know I really was it was very
visceral when I when I was there uh
writing
um probably because it's a day that I
have relived so many times in my mind
your mum calls you and says from what I
read in the book she's very to the point
about what's happened she says Daniel is
dead
she
called me and the phone rang and I sat
on the bed and said hello in the kind of
you know normal cheery way and she said
Daniel's dead and that was you know I
can't express how shocking that is
because you he was fine you know so
there was nothing wrong with Daniel he
wasn't ill he'd never been ill you know
he'd never had anything wrong with him
so it was so just mind-blowing to hear
you know I I my in my mind immediately
created a narrative that he had been run
over or he had been in a car accident I
decided quickly that he was in a car
because he was 16 nearly he was 15 going
on 16. maybe one of the older boys that
he knew had just passed his test maybe
he'd been taken and I had him driving
down this road that I knew in Leeds and
this is where it happened and and then
very quickly my mom started to tell me
actually what had happened that was not
what happened at all he'd he collapsed
in the garden he was playing football
um with my dad and my little brother and
my little brother was six sure Jordan
and he'd just gone over to get football
and he collapsed and died and that was
it that was like that was as much as my
mum knew at that point because by this
point she'd been to hospital and she had
um already kind of got home which sounds
really bizarre saying that in 2022
because now we would have been on the
phone the minute he collapsed you know
she would have rung me and said but they
didn't have mobile phones and or if they
had a mobile phone it was very you know
basic I don't even know if they had a
car phone and so the immediate thing was
to get him to hospital and to get an
ambulance and so to not include
everybody in that process so I was in
London she was in Leeds and then they
were at the hospital and then they came
home and it was hours later that I found
out which again seemed strange you know
that I I didn't know that this was all
happening I wasn't being given a
blow-by-blow account of of what was
happening so I all I had was at that
point her information which was very
scant that
something had happened to his heart his
heart just stopped and the Doctor Who
was at a e or the emergency section of
the hospital when they arrived happened
to be the Doctor Who give him birth to
me who to help my mum deliver me and he
was the old lead United doctor and
so he'd known the family for a very long
time it was a complete coincidence he
was doing a shift on a bank holiday and
he just walked out of theater an hour
after my brother had gone in and you
know shook his head and and it's that
kind of nightmare nightmare scenario for
any any family any parent that you know
they just didn't they believed he was
going into hospital because he got a
heat stroke or something and they you
know in their heads they created what it
was a hot day he must have been
dehydrated they did not expect that as
the outcome and my mum had phoned her
mum who lived in Leeds and and so a
couple of the family members were at the
hospital which was also strange you know
that they would be there and so it was a
a completely
just it sounded fanciful to me I
couldn't I couldn't get my head around
the idea that this very fit young man
would just collapse and I I want you
know I wanted to immediately wanted to
know kind of more but there was nothing
you know and that's a really frustrating
and and there was no internet to go and
go okay what how could how can a young
person die you know how does this happen
and we now know of course so much more
about um cardiac arrest and the young
and there's a you know
uh hypertrophic cardiomyopathy is what
he was diagnosed with and that means
basically the heart just stops without
warning and we've seen very famous
incidents in in football
um Christian Eriksen the Danish
footballer at the last Euros collapsed
on the pitch and his life was saved
because he was in the perfect place for
that to happen there was medical
resource around you know people knew
what they were doing and Daniel was in
the garden you know there was nothing
there so he was he was never going to
survive that but if you you know if you
he'd been somewhere where there was a
defibrillator or he was in a hospital
when it happened you know he may well
have survived but at the time obviously
we just couldn't get our heads around it
I read in the book that the neighbor
tried to resuscitate him so we had a
neighbor who was a he'd worked on oil
rigs offshore and he had paramedic
qualifications he wasn't actually a
paramedic but he'd done some quality so
my mum thought oh Morris next door he'll
know what to do and my mom was when she
was telling me like later and then you
years later when we discussed it she was
she said she was so relaxed about it
because
because he wasn't to her he wasn't dead
he just collapsed and you know nobody
could think of him as being an unfit
person so she wasn't relaxed and said
she wasn't urgent but she just thought
Morris will sort this out you know
Morris came around and he couldn't get
him back he couldn't get his heart going
and but they still didn't use the word I
don't think they said his heart stopped
because nobody wants to say that to her
parent so Morris obviously put him in
the in the ambulance I think knowing
that his heart stopped but my parents
didn't know his heart stopped they
thought he was collapsed or he was in
some kind of like you know heat induced
coma or something had happened to him
that that meant he just wasn't
responsive I think that was they thought
he wasn't responsive as opposed to he
was actually dead and then my dad said
that my dad went with him in the
ambulance and my dad said at one point
the ambulance went round and bend really
quickly and his arm flew out and landed
in my dad's lap and my dad said that
when the arm when his arm landed that's
when he knew he was dead because he said
he just felt that there was no life
there was nothing that showed any
response and
so his his Hope was
crushed
you you look at your life as before and
after that moment
what was life like after that moment
the immediate aftermath like the weeks
after something
that is is a strange mix of
um activity and energy you know because
you're
organizing funerals people are kind of
coming hundreds of people descending on
the house constantly people coming and
and actually there was a kind of
um an energy in the house that it just
kept you you just kept going and doing
things my mom didn't she very much
stopped and she went into almost a kind
of after the funeral she was almost
catatonic and just kind of almost sat
and did nothing for about a month but I
think I was the eldest child my sister
at the time was modeling in Japan she'd
flown home for the funeral but then went
off quite quickly afterwards my Dad
decided to go on tour with Wales who was
managing so I decided my life in London
was over and I was going to stay home
and try and help and my mum had a
fledgling property business so I was
kind of running around doing errands for
her and trying to kind of like keep this
energy going that we'd experienced
during the week leading up to the
funeral and then suddenly it all starts
to quieten down and people stopped
coming round people stopped bringing
food around people stopped ringing to
see if you're okay and and then this
kind of quietness descends on on the
house and the home and the and everybody
in it and and that's when you really
start facing grief because grief
um I didn't have room to come in you
know in those first few weeks there was
no there was no space for it it was all
about energy and activity and trying to
do your best for everybody and then the
reality you know just on a daily basis
of
kind of I mean every day even when the
energy was there you'd wake up just with
those first thoughts of the day would
just oh God
you know it really is it's happened it's
real it's not it's not a dream and
getting yourself mobilized but then
after the energy left those oh God this
is real those feelings have just despair
and kind of sadness
it just took longer to get yourself
going and you know you do feel kind of
just sometimes or you did feel
immobilized with that sadness and
um as a family it just kind of pushes
everybody off into kind of different
Corners if you like it you know it's
like a sledgehammer coming down and just
shattering something that had been a
very tight unit so
um
it then takes a long long time I think
for things to get back to any kind of
normalcy or what you can now call your
new normal
are there certain days or certain
memories of when things were
hardest for the family do you have like
um I was speaking here yesterday to um
Whitney from who's the founding CEO of
Bumble and she went through her own
version of grief sort of more it's a
Professional Grief that she she refers
to and she says there's kind there was
kind of a day there was a day when I
remember it being the hardest day in
that period and that that represented
the bottom and from there on it was the
kind of sort of the climb out of that
moment did was there a bottom moment for
you was there a day where you think that
was the hardest day of all
I don't remember there being one day in
particular because even years afterwards
you know a few years afterwards I could
find myself
sobbing you know over something that had
seen or I'd read or when I started
working in Telly I remember I used to be
obsessed when I started working in
football with the dates of players
births because they would be his age and
I knew that he might be playing in that
match or he could have you know and so
there would be something that would just
kind of throw me or I wouldn't I wasn't
necessarily looking for it but then it
would just occur to me that they were
the same age and you do that thing where
you wonder well first of all would he be
playing in this match what kind of play
would he have been I wonder if he'd have
had a girlfriend by now I wonder if he'd
have met somebody he wanted to marry oh
now I wonder if he'd have children you
know and you do that through the life of
the person that you know
is no longer with you because you want
to keep their you know kind of their
memory life but also I think
um you wonder then if everything would
have been different in the family
because ultimately my parents divorced
and my dad
was using alcohol to you know to
medicate himself and you know it's a lot
to put on Daniel's shoulders but you
think would if he hadn't died would
would we all still be together would
this you know with the family unit have
survived and so there are those days you
know where just years later you could be
flawed so I don't think there was one
day but what happens is you start to
notice oh a few weeks have gone by now
and life's been quite good and I've been
able to find joy in things and
um I've done something and not thought
but would it have been better if Daniel
had been here and you go through all
those anniversaries you know so the
first year of the first Christmas the
first birthdays all of those things
that's that's the you know getting
through those anniversaries is always
tough for anybody who loses any anybody
of significance in their lives
um but with him it was things like the
16th birthday the 18th birthday the 20
you know there's all these big kind of
landmark occasions and and then you have
your own children and you start to look
at his life differently because when he
when my son got to 15 it was nearly 16
my kid's birthday is only a few days
away from his birthday I realized when
my son turned 16.
I realized that I'd been worried about
him not being 16.
because
because Daniel never got there so I you
know I did
I did have a fear that I was going to
repeat history
we never we never taught how to grieve
nobody ever teaches us that and I and
it's
is
it's a shame because it going through
your life and not experiencing grief in
some form is
would be
it's almost impossible to do that and I
think sometimes I I worry about grief
because you haven't had enough because I
haven't had enough
and I also have this sort of impending
feeling that it's coming but
when you look back at that moment
um post Daniel's passing
what do you think what advice would you
give to someone on how to properly
grieve
um in hindsight with your wisdom now
about that situation and how it
transpired and how it stayed with you is
there anything you can say about how how
one Grieves properly it's such a
personal thing grief isn't it because it
depends on your relation your own
relationship with death you know what
what you feel about mortality how you
feel about that person obviously is
hugely significant also what they did in
their life you know I find myself I've
had lots of relatives I think four
who've lived to be a hundred four or
five so I've been to funerals of people
at 105 and that was a joyous life you
know and that was a great celebration so
I think it always depends on all those
factors those relationships I think the
one thing that I would say from our
experience with Daniel which was a life
cut very short and very sudden I think
it's and it doesn't matter if it isn't
sudden and I've wrestled with that as
well we all did about Daniel like would
it have been better if we'd known what
if he'd been ill and we had time to to
get our heads around it would have made
any difference and there's no right or
wrong way you know to lose a child there
is no easy way to lose a child but I
think counseling and talking to people
is really really helpful for me I found
having somebody to process what was
going on was really helpful and finding
Kindred Spirits as well you know people
who've been through similar experiences
and you find them
without wanting to sound kind of too
kind of woo-woo spiritual but I think
those people come come into your life as
well at the time that you need them and
then you've you've got to be open to
them being there but when I met my
husband that was something we
immediately connected on because he lost
a cousin who was like a brother to him
who was um he was in his 30s but had two
small children and my my husband was
only 19 when that happened and
um that you know that was a tragic
accident and again a sudden death and
that devastated his his young world and
I think if you
have people in your world who you know
you can talk to like that I think it's
really really helpful
I was when you were talking about the
week after Daniel's passing and the
energy in the house and how it almost
hadn't set in because you had this
almost distraction there was things to
do there was other things to keep the
brain on so many of us I mean we
distract ourselves after moments of
trauma and grief in a number of
different ways but distraction
um doesn't solve the problem does it
just kind of kicks the can down the road
yeah and I think although
um I did
experience after that immediate kind of
Rush of energy there was a silence for
you know time for sadness to come in I
did default back into that kind of
frenetic energy when I went to
University which was only a few months
later I became the queen of joining in
you know so I would join every club that
I could I was in the drama Society the
Union society I would you know can I
join this netball team can I do this can
I do that can I've got my degree I'm
going to get a job you know I was
working at weekends I I filled every
hour and I love being busy but there was
definitely a sense of running away from
from what was going on I think in the
background of my life
on top of that sort of you know
workaholism
um
how did Daniel's passing change your
perspective of Life generally and you
know one I'll be honest when I read
um about the passing of Daniel there was
this real moment of pause when I was
reading there alone there was this
moment of pause at the prospect that he
was
half my age and he suddenly his suddenly
his heart stopped and it made me think
honestly when I was really my brain went
so anyone's heart can stop at any time
they can be perfectly healthy they can
be an athlete and their heart can just
stop at any time and you sit there like
feeling my own heart and I'm wearing
this band though where I've been wearing
for the last couple of weeks checking
your heartbeat she tells me everything
about my heart and this morning it's
funny because it said my heart my H my
heart variability scores like way way
down typically means you've been doing
something stressful or exerting yourself
too much and I as I saw it was like
there was like a five minute difference
between This Heart warning that's
flashing on my band and reading that in
the book yeah how did how did the
fragility of life
um
and your experience of the fragility of
life change your perspective on life
itself
I think two things one and it took me a
while to correct this I In My Head
Thought although I was busy getting you
know getting busy and doing things and
doing my degree and everything else
there was part of me that thought okay
now terrible things can happen at any
time so my so tomorrow another terrible
thing could happen and I was almost
waiting for that next thing because if
if he can die and he's that healthy
looking and he'd never complained about
any chest pains he was an athlete like a
proper athlete you know he just he could
run and run and run if he can die like
that well terrible things can happen all
the time but I didn't Express this but
it was my kind of there was a feeling
inside me that that was possible so so
there was that that part of the kind of
the process you know was going on inside
me even though I was busy I was
expecting a terrible thing and I had
this therapist a few years later who she
just looked at me one day and she
because I was obviously manifesting this
or talking about it again and she said
your [ __ ] things happened
and now then she and um that was such a
power thing to say because although
another [ __ ] thing can happen of course
you know it just it stopped me it kind
of really stopped me in my tracks and I
thought I've got to reframe this and
stop thinking or stop believing that
something else is coming down the tracks
that I'm gonna have to deal with and I'm
not a natural Warrior so to be in that
kind of state so it wasn't worry you
know it wasn't me sitting there thinking
oh I'm not gonna cross the road because
the car's gonna come it wasn't about
taking risks it was just a self-defense
mechanism ready for it I'm ready for it
something's gonna happen and I'm I'm
ready I can see you know and so it
wasn't I wanted to stop my life so I
didn't I didn't get hurt or you know
people I loved didn't get hurt but I
wanted to be ready next time because I
wasn't ready the last time what's this
what are the symptoms of that of kind of
expecting a terrible thing to happen
yeah what are the symptoms so not not
not hanging at the time I was single and
I was definitely not attracting the
right people into my life you know and I
was I was not going out with people who
were enhancing me as a person or my life
because why would I want to have any
kind of long-term commitment with
anybody who'd treat me well or be nice
to me because I was you know I wasn't
going to commit to something so I may as
well be with somebody who wasn't that
nice to me who didn't make me feel good
about myself because because it was all
it was all very you know transient so
um I wasn't I wasn't giving
um I wasn't giving myself any kind of
chance of of that happening because of
my kind of charging through you know and
um and actually okay if you're horrible
to me that's fine I've dealt with this I
can you know but that's not really good
for your kind of deep self-esteem you
know we talk about earlier you talked
about how I had good self-esteem leaving
leaving school and feeling good about
myself
um but that wasn't that wasn't very
um productive in terms of you know good
self-esteem so I suppose that's that's
how it kind of manifested itself and
again there's that commitment thing to
to you know to people and things and
I suppose a feeling that um I was losing
empathy and that's really important
thing to to hang on to and
um and while I wouldn't have expressed
it as losing empathy at the time it was
losing patience you know kind of oh
that's that's so trivial but it's not
trivial to that person and having an
understanding of that is really
important and actually using what you've
learned about loss and grief in a more
positive way and not such a destructive
way
age 19 Metro FM that's your sort of
first step into uh
broadcasting yeah very few people in
this in this world will ever reach the
heights that you've reached in
broadcasting but so many of them would
want to I've met many many young people
that want to to get to where you are in
your career
um there's not a lot of seats at the
table at the very top
um so I'm trying to understand in
hindsight how you got to that table
and I know nobody ever likes asking me
answering these questions because at
some point you're gonna have to
compliment yourself to some degree
you're gonna have to highlight something
that's a good characteristic in yourself
and people don't people feel
uncomfortable with but with doing that
for some reason but
um because we're not American yeah yeah
oh my God Americans if I ask them that
question not only do they they tell me
but they the story sounds amazing it's
so like chance and they're a hero in the
story
everyone else British people they're
like well you know ask someone else yeah
well how often do you say the word I was
very lucky because I was very lucky and
we shrouded in this this luck you know
luck happened to us and and there is
always an element of timing with things
isn't there and I I got my break at
Metro through meeting a guy at a New
Year's Eve party the the winter before I
went to University and I said to him I
really want to work in broadcasting and
he ran a radio station and he said when
you come to Durham which was nine months
later make sure you come and see me and
I'll give you some work experience and
I'd already done work experience on
radio stations and newspapers so so I
thought of that so I waited about 10
minutes after arriving in Durham and I
went to a phone box because we didn't
have mobiles and filled it with my
Temperance pieces and had to wait for
the receptionist to put me through and I
remember standing in the rain in Durham
kind of waiting for him and he said oh
hello because he was quite surprised
first of all I was calling before
freshers week it even started but
secondly he was probably going hang on a
minute where did I meet you what and he
said okay come and see me you know next
week or the week after and we'll have a
chat about what it is you want to do and
that was it that was my kind of the
person I could just cling on to and get
into somewhere that was a professional
outfit wasn't student radio this was a
commercial radio station with real
people living real lives you know and
and with mortgages so their work was
important and
um I got there and he he gave me a
chance he trained me up for about four
or five months and then by the Christmas
of my first term I got my first paid
shift on the radio station and that was
the start
eventually you've got the breakfast show
right when I graduated when you
graduated soon you must have been at
Metro for what three to four years by
the time so I was three years yeah three
years
even at that early stage in your
broadcasting career
what were you because we all know what
we're good at Often by like comparison
of peers this is like where comparisons
and can sometimes be quite helpful did
you have an indication of what you were
good at as a broadcaster versus your
peers what was your USP
um I wasn't necessarily comparing myself
to anybody else but what I felt I was
getting good at when I was doing the
breakfast show was being responsive and
being able to ad-lib situations and find
the funny or find the quirking because
on a breakfast show you know you're kind
of you're you're riffing backwards and
forwards with your co-host you're
responding to the day's news you're
talking about things that are going on
in people's lives and I realized that I
I could do that quite well without
feeling
self-conscious about what I was saying
you know I was I was able to to kind of
match my co-host quite well on those
things who's had a lot more experience
than me
um the other stuff there's a lot of
stuff that you can learn to be good at
you know you can learn to read the news
Well which I initially started out doing
the news and you can learn to um edit a
story because I was technically having
to do you know those kinds of things but
I think that was something that was a
little bit more ethereal and difficult
to nebulous and difficult to kind of you
know hone and train somebody to do so I
I felt like that was something that I
wanted to expand on and that was
something that I could
certainly take forwards as a quality you
know and it certainly is something that
is good in live broadcasting to be able
to think on your feet and be you know
able to turn a story into something else
and talk to somebody on the spot who's
just walked on to set you know all and
fill five minutes of time all those
things that live broadcasting needs you
know those qualities that it needs and
then eventually Sky call and you end up
going to work for Sky Sports yeah at 25
years old I was younger than that yeah
because that was a year after I joined
Metro which I would have been 22 so 23
so I was 23 when I joined Sky Sports so
my dream had been to work in London I
wanted to leave you know the Northeast
and find a job in London so when Sky
Sports saw me doing touchline interviews
at St James's park because by this point
I got a Saturday job because the boss at
the stage you could see I loved sport
and he was like why don't you do
touchline interviews at St James's park
for us um on a Saturday then Skye had
seen me on the touchline and decided
that they needed more women in front of
camera and asked me if I'd be interested
in going down for a screen test so I had
basically a month where my life just
turned because I had this sliding doors
moment where I made the call straight
away and as you've discovered with the
call to jars I wasn't shy of picking up
the phone and making the call I made the
call the next morning to the person I've
been told to phone and then within a
couple of days I was on a flight to
London to go and see the the boss at Sky
and do the screen test and then within a
few hours I think of getting home that
night I got a phone call
asking me if I'd go and work there and
negotiating a package to go and work
there so it was a really really exciting
kind of period of my life that I you
know hadn't really planned I didn't know
how I was going to get to London I was I
was looking for
um adverts in kind of uh broadcast and
various places you know trying to find
something that could get me there and I
rang up an agency a talent agency I
looked at people whose careers I liked
and thought Oh I wonder who they're
managed by I'll ring them and they were
very sweet and said oh well dude come
back to us when you've got some
experience because I had no experience I
had this little TV job in the Northeast
and I just didn't know how I was gonna
get there but I knew I had to for things
to progress
for anyone that's listening to this that
has big dreams of you know going into
certain industries especially Industries
where there's seems to be quite
um at the very top it seems to be quite
a small table when you look back at your
own journey and the decisions you made
the Small Things in hindsight the
moments of sort of serendipity
um what advice would you give to someone
who is trying to get somewhere High
we're at the very top of that tree is a
is quite a small table what are the
things that you did right maybe
accidentally or intentionally
I think what I did through University
and that could be could have been Post
University I worked so hard to I did
shifts that were very unsociable I was
doing three o'clock four o'clock in the
morning get UPS to go and do new shifts
and I did late night love shows I did
all the kind of things that you know are
the unglamorous end of that job because
I was being offered the shift and I took
them and I had to juggle that with my
law degree but I I innately felt that it
was almost like I was doing an
apprenticeship in what I wanted to do at
the same time and as well as earning me
you know some cash as a student is
always handy but I was getting this
experience and the hours and hours and
hours of doing that meant that when I
did get the opportunity at Sky and I I
was felt confident about picking the
phone up because I knew I'd had all
these hours I wasn't just somebody who'd
done a few shows and you know even if I
just had the one year working there at
post-grad I don't think I would have
felt as confident but I knew I'd put
those those hours in and I felt I wasn't
going to be
um I mean we've all got an element of
imposter syndrome but I didn't feel I
was going to be out of place because I
knew I'd had all that that experience
those hours so I think you've got to
you've got to put the groundwork in you
know and not expect things to happen too
quickly in the sense of you know don't
don't over Force those those things that
you'll feel the times right you know you
feel like okay I knew I was ready to
move on about around that time but in
that year of post working full-time it
wasn't towards the end until towards the
end that I really felt I was ready I
knew that all that stuff I was doing was
really important in building the the you
know the building blocks of your of your
career so I think it's really important
to to put those foundations down and
you'll always benefit from that you know
it's never a waste of time taking an
opportunity from somebody saying yes to
something I said yes to things I talk
about them in the book that I was
nowhere near in that year that I was
working in uh local radio I didn't know
how to do it but I said yes to stuff
because I knew it was going to give me
experience and and then obviously when
you find yourself somewhere like Sky
which is I was at the very much at the
bottom of the wrong you know the ladder
and I was learning again I was starting
to I knew a whole new set of experiences
then you have to have that um hopefully
I had a little bit of kind of humility
and such okay I need to learn I don't
know what I'm doing here and and then
people will you'll find people who will
be your teacher in that environment so I
think it's really important to I always
like say to my kids about you know it's
the expression your mum would have said
to you kind of like you know don't run
before you can walk right and um and it
sounds really boring because everybody
wants to run everybody wants to get
there quicker and and you can get there
quickly but you've just got to put some
hours in first and I think you'll stay
there longer this episode is brought to
you by Mercedes-Benz who recently got in
touch to support the Diary of a CEO
thank you I'm a huge fan of their cars
in fact I have one of my own which is
like an office on Wheels and they have
an exciting wide range of cars that I'd
love to tell you about the Mercedes EQ
is the luxury electric range of
Mercedes-Benz and it is available across
many models from the SUVs to the saloons
meaning they're ideal for all business
needs the Innovative Next Generation
technology found in all Mercedes EQ cars
is really Paving the way for the
electric car industry to make your
electric car switch so much easier are
Mercedes-Benz has a service called
Mercedes me charge it's a subscription
which provides you with access to a wide
network of charging stations across the
entirety of the UK the app shows you the
precise location and current
availability and price at the selected
charging station of your choice and this
enables businesses to effectively plan
their route ahead of their Journey you
can search Mercedes-Benz Fleet today to
discover how the Mercedes EQ car range
can help your business get ahead and if
you already drive a Mercedes EQ let me
know how you find it
quick one from our longest standing
sponsor hero I I can't tell you over the
last I'd say over the last really it's
been about two and a half years it was
really um post pandemic how much my
health has become such a huge priority
in my life and I have this laser laser
focused on what I'm putting into my body
it's funny because as you get older you
can start to feel the things you're
putting into your body more and more and
more
um and if I if I put something into my
body especially things like gluten if I
put those things in my body I feel them
tremendously the next day my energy
levels my sleep and everything in
between huel has been probably the most
important partner in my health Journey
because
I've been in the boardrooms I've been to
their offices
tens and tens and tens and tens of times
I've seen how they make their decisions
on nutrition and I trust it most of my
team that are in this room with me
consume it and get the benefits of it
too so if you haven't already tried your
do so
your next period of life was at Sky
um
which was as you write about it in the
book a very sort of male
dominated egotistical environment
how did that
shape you how did that impact you go
walking into Sky back in those days I
mean everybody in football was a man
right you say in the book I think you
say 90 of the like people behind the
camera were men
um it was a very male dominated
environment and it was obviously very
early in the infancy of sky sky was only
a few years old at that point the
Premier League was only a few years old
so a lot of Sky's early recruits if you
like were from Fleet Street the
hard-nosed journalists who kind of done
you know pounded the shifts and gone
kind of you know to all the matches over
the years and from and again a very
male-dominated environment but it was
tough and I've talked to a lot recently
to people about the 90s not to do in my
book but just about how it was there was
this thing happening in the 90s that you
you've kind of went along with a bit and
actually I don't really feel comfortable
with I'm not a ladder you know I'm not
there was this ladder culture and there
was a drinking culture and
um it was all about the music of the
time and everything else and I think
football was in this Center of all of
this as well because of the the newness
of sky and the newness of the Premier
League
um and it would have been easy I think
to to lose yourself in that and there
were times where I felt like I was
trying to conform and you know be the
person that you know was able to banter
with the lads and have that kind of you
know ripping and all of that but it
didn't make me feel very good you know I
didn't really like that person so
um I was I wasn't completely at ease
with myself I would say there you wrote
In the book that you didn't like
yourself very much during that period I
didn't like myself very much but I
always seem to forget that the next time
I was drinking the anger disappointment
and self-doubt that such destructive
Behavior brings was coming home to roost
yeah I think um I wasn't very healthy
I'd gone from being somebody who had run
half marathons when I was in Newcastle a
really brilliant diet to suddenly I was
doing late shifts eating badly drinking
more alcohol than I'd ever drunk when I
was at University you know I wasn't
massive Drinker and suddenly it was a
bar culture you know it was kind of
after a shift to go for a drink shifts
would finish at 10 you shouldn't start
drinking at 10. you know it's not a good
time of day to start drinking weekends I
knew nobody when I first arrived in in
London so it was
um you know what what's what's everybody
doing how do I get social life you know
where do I go what my you know so you'd
be invited somewhere that would involve
being in a bar or being involved in a
club and
um and so I yeah I was slipping into
kind of bad habits and um I think
there's part of me feeling like though
although this this is what it is to be
an adult you know is this how I you know
is this how I behave now
um and I was there was a good 18 months
really where I was putting on weight
didn't feel good about myself at all and
then that it becomes a self-filling
prophecy almost you know and you kind of
go oh well I've I'll put on weight now I
may as well just carry on eating the
Magnums I may as well carry on eating
the um you know drinking the Chardonnay
and
um I wasn't yeah I was I wasn't happy
you know I didn't enjoy that but um but
it just it kind of became a habit I
guess you know
in the talk about the 90s it's quite
hard for us for someone like myself to
imagine the culture
in an office and in a working
environment at that time when I was
reading some of the
um the quotes from the book about how
you would walk through the office and
someone would shout at you about who
which football player you've been
sleeping with or someone comes up to in
the office and makes a comment about
your ass until he tells you that it's
going to drop by the time you're 30.
those things seem quite Unthinkable in
the modern I know especially somebody of
your age and when I told my daughter
who's 17 she's just you know it defies
belief for her and yet when I speak to
people my age they reminisce almost
about I spoke to an actress the other
day who's same age as me and she was
talking about things that people would
say in auditions even and you know
um and I think it's
it's really positive that you think that
is so Unthinkable you know because that
means things have changed and I think
it's um amazing actually kind of that
for me it doesn't seem that long ago but
actually you know it's a few decades ago
and Society has changed our expectation
of each other has changed our
expectation of how we're to be treated
in the workplace has changed and that
comes through representation as as well
because those offices were very male
dominated and I think they were very
there were probably a lot of men in
there that weren't comfortable with that
but they didn't feel they could speak up
because of that culture that was there
and that's not healthy for any business
or any environment you know I always
quote um I made a documentary on women
in football and I remember Karen Brady
saying to me that who is the CEO of West
Ham and her saying to me I never invest
my own money in a company that doesn't
have a woman on the board this was about
14 years ago 13 years ago I made this
documentary and she said not because I
think that's gonna you know that I'm
trying to make a point but I know that
that board is going to be more
representative in terms of how it views
its business how it views its future and
its budgets and everything else that is
plans for the business so I always
remember that because when I look at
that office I think well how could this
how could that environment ever really
have different voices and different
opinions and because the big loud ones
the big loud kind of more misogynistic
ones were dominating everybody else and
and people didn't feel they could speak
up you know and didn't feel they could
they could talk and it didn't look like
Society it didn't look like a football
Terrace or it didn't look like um or how
we perceive a football Terrace to look
now which is people from different
ethnicities and people from different
backgrounds and different um sexual
orientation all those different things
that um that that office didn't
represent and that office was as I say
Not Unusual that would have been across
many Industries how things looked so I
think it's it's really important that we
have now more representation diversity
in everything that we do because of that
but um at the time that was really
normal
so you know that wasn't
um I didn't feel like I was in an
unusual place I didn't feel like oh I
wish I wish I went somewhere else where
it was a bit you know people were a bit
kinder your podcast is called midpoint
your book is called the first half
there's a theme going on yeah what why
um
midpoint
came about uh as a lockdown project
something I've been intending to do for
ages and had the time and it felt like I
was in the middle of my life and it
happened while I was in a pandemic and
it felt very much like a time of
introspection and you know asking
yourself questions about what next what
does it mean to go through this period
where a lot of people start to
experience
um you know the midlife crisis a lot of
people refer to which you know obviously
in the sitcom that's where the bloke
gets you know some leather jeans and a
Harley-Davidson and runs off into the
sunset with somebody 25 years younger
than him or you know or um Shirley
Valentine flies off to Greece and finds
a lover you know so you get these kind
of very caricatured ideas of what
midlife is but for most people you know
they stay with their families and they
you know they work through something
that happens to them and what I
discovered with women is uh menopause I
didn't really know anything about it
going into lockdown and then I learned a
lot about it and then I was having one
and and that is a huge topic of
conversation that you know rightly has
grown and become something that people
are more aware of but also it's for me
it was more about the I started off
wanting to talk to people who'd done
something different in midlife so my
first guest was John Bishop who at 39
was selling pharmaceutical drugs and at
40 was a stand-up comedian which was a
massive career change and I like the
idea of doing something really different
in the middle of your life and not
feeling you have to keep going until the
end with the thing that you've gone on
you know the path to do and it's it's
obviously fanciful to say that anybody
can change their trajectory in midlife
because circumstances will dictate that
you have to keep paying your mortgage or
you have to keep you know food on the
table so it's not possible just to stop
and start something else but I do like
the idea that you can you can make a
change because we're all going to work
so much longer than our parents you know
had to or our grandparents had to just
the way society's going and you may as
well do something that you really love
and feel nourished by so midpoint came
about really because of all those kind
of things that I was thinking about it
was a self-serving project you know it
was like I want to talk to people are
doing interesting things
um and it's been really a joy to do you
know and to to kind of you know what
this environment's like it's a brilliant
way to have a conversation and you get
to talk about things that you find
interesting and then the person you're
talking to Sparks interest in you as
well so
um I'm about a six Series in so I'm
nowhere near as you know prolific as you
Stephen but obviously it's um it's a
kind of side hustle yeah well this side
is a side hustle in my bedroom so it's
crazy it's crazy um you know now we've
got these cameras which is mad yeah on
that point of the midlife crisis thing
is there any truth in that are there
regrets that show up in you know that
you've seen from your conversations in
midlife that that were maybe not as
obvious beforehand priorities change
values become clearer
there is definitely something in it in
in the midlife
um change you know I think the physical
changes that all women go through it
shouldn't underestimate kind of how that
can affect them and their families and
and that's why a greater understanding
of that is really important especially
you know women who've worked so hard in
their careers and they you know the
stories and the anecdotes you hear about
women just pulling themselves away from
it because of the physical effects of
menopause and I have a really
high-powered friend who's that one of
the top she's one of the top hedge
funders in the country sits on the board
of one of the biggest and she said to me
well I'm going on testosterone because
there's no way I'm working this hard and
letting a bloke come and take my job so
testosterone is one of the hormones that
depletes in in um uh midlife and women
so if you go on HRT you could take
progesterone estrogen and testosterone
but people don't realize women have
testosterone you know that they they
need it and I was laughing because she
was like as if I'm going to kind of give
up this but actually a lot of women do
give up that career because of the
feelings that they have of anxiety and
low self-esteem and you get brain fog
there's so many things physically that
happen to women at that time so I think
that has an impact obviously on on lives
but also
um and then what I realized when I
started looking into how many
relationships break up but not because
actually those two people don't love
each other anymore but because if the
woman's going through all of that and
the man's feeling kind of like she
doesn't love me anymore what's going on
you know and they the relationship
breaks down because of a lack of
understanding and communication but also
I think because you've done the same
thing a lot of people have done the same
thing for nearly 30 years you know if
they've been on a traditional career
trajectory and then they feel bored or
they need something to kind of you know
give them a kick and then there's the
mortality question as well because you
suddenly look at your parents and a lot
of people in that age the parents are
you know in their 70s or maybe 80s and
and looking like they're nearing the end
of their lives and that makes you
question you know the rest of your life
so there are so many issues that come up
and time to think as well because your
kids are getting to an age where they're
not the same kind of Demands on your
time through them so they're they're
flying you know they're doing their own
thing so you have time to think and
space to think so it is definitely it's
a thing that's why I think think why I'm
so intrigued by the topic is how do I
design my life now at 30 to try and
um limit the effects of that mid
midpoint
um
confusion or dissatisfaction that people
often experience and that you've kind of
accounted there one of the things that I
suspect is going to help is for me to
stay really in touch with the things
that I enjoy doing that I know
um in no way pay me or provide for me
professionally just like DJing and so
for your fulfillment yeah you know in
life is not just from the things that
earn you cash you know and I think the
older you get you realize how important
those other things are the Hobbies is
that you know if that is a hobby or if
it's
volunteering you know and I don't mean
that just kind of working in a you know
help the ages shop but giving your
talents to other people mentoring people
and we do a lot of Kenny and I do a lot
of stuff with various Charities that we
feel you know very passionate about or
um giving your time up to people I think
those things are really important
because as you become more financially
secure it is your time isn't it that's
the most valuable you know kind of thing
that you have and um and if you can give
your time to other people like that it's
it's very very rewarding and and then
you find you know kind of passion
projects as well that things that you've
felt in the past you haven't had time to
commit to and I want to know Kenny my
husband is really into being outside you
know he's he's loves making things and
I'm like building things and doing
things so he will literally be on a zoom
doing his business call and then you'll
realize he's got half an hour and he'll
go out and he'll be on his track to kind
of raking something and building
something and you know that for him is
how he is just loving his kind of
midlife balance you know but he couldn't
have done that 10 years ago when he was
first really building his business he
wouldn't have you know he just wouldn't
have worked so I think you you get to a
stage where you also give yourself that
time to do those things and allow
yourself you know and you'll be you know
you'll have so many other interests
business interests and things that have
along the way have you know kind of
given you great satisfaction so I'm not
worried about you having any kind of
mid-life uh crisis you said you
discovered you had you were going
through menopause
um at the age of 47 yeah I realized I
had perimenopausal symptoms because I
didn't really know what it was I just
felt this sense of like oh nothing feels
as exciting anymore nothing feels as
joyous I'm not getting the same
satisfaction out of stuff and and that
was so not me and then I did one of my
podcasts I was with Mariela frostrop and
she started talking about the menopause
she's a bit older than me and I was like
oh my God these things these things you
talk of I recognize them and afterwards
she recommended you know a go speak to
this doctor that she had seen and
um and sure enough I was bang in the
middle of you know what what was the
physical the physical manifestation
obviously of the menopauses eventually
you stop menstruating but before then
you have all these other things going on
low self-esteem anxiety brain fog you
know and this is all to do with your
hormones dropping off all the jobs that
these hormones did before they no longer
can do and that includes also your
immune system going down and you know
and this is in the middle of a pandemic
so at that point my immune system's low
I don't want my immune system to be you
know any weaker than anybody else's so
it was a good time to find out and uh
and I you know knowing that I could
rebalance my hormones as well and
um I was so relieved when I did take HRT
to feel myself again because I had been
feeling like I remember one day having
this absolute kind of family meeting
crisis meeting putting everybody to the
table saying right nobody around here is
pulling their way and really reading the
right act to everybody and I was and the
point where I got like I thought they're
not taking me seriously so I said if
this carries on I'm getting a flat in
Beaconsfield I know which is a little
town near where we live and they all
looked at me like I gone mad because
this has come from nowhere and of course
the kids were like close to tears and I
was like because I'm not going to be and
I realized now I look back and I was I
was just totally you know
sad about kind of how I was feeling and
I just didn't feel I was you know as I
didn't have as much fight and tenacity
and energy and you know and this was all
menopausal symptoms really um I mean now
with the hindsight and the distance
that's between it you know they laugh
about that whole day that was that was
the day where we realized mum was having
a menopause but thank God I found out
right and I didn't actually go and look
at renting a flat in beckinsfield to
serve them all right and you know it's a
real perfect Confluence when you have a
woman in her late 40s and her kids are
teenagers because their hormones are
going crazy in the other direction and
they're going through puberty and
everything's happening the other way you
know and so Kenny was very really wanted
to know what was going on with me so
he'd listen to my podcasts and he
learned so much about the menopause from
the female guest Davina McCall who's the
you know doing so much great work in
this space and she was talking about it
and he came in one day and he sat down
and he said to me I've just listened
I've been out in a dog walk and I've
just listened to Davina and he said okay
so if you start taking HRT and your
hormones kind of start going back again
you know and what happens to me are my
hormones dropping off a cliff how you
know am I gonna I said no no men are
different and and he kept going on about
it I said look just go and do a well-man
test or something because you need to
satisfy yourself that you're okay you
know and um it was through doing this
well-man test that he found out he had
prostate cancer so um his his kind of um
his motivation for doing it was to see
if his testosterone was still kind of
you know functioning at a high level and
they said to him listen don't worry
about your hormones they're fine you've
got to worry about your PSA to cut a
long story short he ended up having his
prostate removed and um had prostate
cancer so
um yeah we we in terms of a mid-life a
midlife journey in a midlife experience
there was a lot a lot going on there
obviously with regard to my my journey
kind of bled into him finding out
something that he otherwise wouldn't
have known because unfortunately
prostate cancer is a cancer that you
don't always get symptoms until it's too
late and as his urologist said to him if
you'd had symptoms we might be having a
very different conversation
wow hmm
so I'm I'm forever grateful that I
started my podcast I think because he
wouldn't have had we wouldn't have had
that conversation
it's a really scary thing to think about
in hindsight if those dots hadn't sort
of connected because like most blokes
this is the thing and he this is why he
did it he did a podcast episode talking
about it like most blokes and especially
one he played International Rugby right
you know he played 70 times for his
country he was used to giving his body a
battering and giving his body putting
his body through it and so he's living
with some of the ramifications of that
you know he has to really look after his
back and his core he's very lucky he
didn't really break too many bones but
you know he knows he has to look after
his body because he put it through a lot
so when he does have aches and pains and
things he often like a lot of men just
ignores them because he thinks that's
part of you know what he'd done to
himself before and that's part of you
know his Sporting Life and this year he
lost one of his very best friends who
played for Scotland with who'd who'd
done just that who'd ignored a lot of
those things thinking it was old
injuries and it turned out he had bowel
cancer and he died and that was um for
him just you know
huge a sense of gratitude that he he had
found out but also a reason for him
wanting to talk about it because men can
be really rubbish at that you know and
it's and it's something that I think we
talked about masculine kind of identity
and earlier on about you know my dad
when he was younger and how he
um the self-preservation and wanting to
you know keep things in in public and
actually that's a lot of that is is men
not always sharing those things so and
not having those conversations candidly
and when he did that on the pro on the
podcast
um the response from men has been
amazing to him you know and I think it's
partly because he's perceived to be
somebody who is a tough rugby player so
if he can talk about it okay I can go to
the doctor and like I can ask them a few
questions am I right in thinking
prostate cancer is the cancer that takes
the life of most men yeah 12 000 men a
year most it's the cancer the biggest
cancer killer of men
he does that Wellness well man test
he eventually goes and has a a test done
for prostate cancer I guess and then he
gets the verdict back
you've been through grief before you've
been through loss before in fact we when
we talked about you know your earlier
years you kind of had that sense of
impending doom when he makes that phone
call to you when you have that
conversation with him
what what is that like what's going on
in your head
so he had a zoom set up with his
urologist because it was at the early
part of this year when we were still not
really you know there was that covert
surgeon and he said okay don't come in
I'll do a zoom with you and Gabby
together and I had made an appointment
uh or a meeting rather with a head of a
production company I was going to be
working with to come to the house at 11.
so Kenny said he's calling at 10 30. I
said yeah great fine 10 30. I was not
expecting anything other than you're
absolutely fine you know I did not
expect negative news didn't expect him
to hear anything other than come back to
me in a year we'll keep an eye on it you
know and um otherwise I wouldn't have
made an appointment with somebody at 11
o'clock and
when his urologist told him I think we
both were just I think Kenny was more
expecting it than me I I very much was
like you're going to be absolutely fine
you know you look at your picture of
health and you know you're on your what
by pushing out massive Watts yesterday
you know and you're You're great and
um we were
shocked stunned because you then you
don't know what that means you know how
bad is it where is it gone all those
things and
um and I think Kenny was really very sad
you know he's just like a feel sadness
in him because he said I feel so well I
I feel sad that inside me this is
happening and I don't know about it and
he you know it was very confusing and
also it's very tied in with your
masculinity and you know kind of the
prostate and so he was he was really
really upset and as you can imagine and
I I just thought right no this is we're
going to sort this this is going to be
absolutely fine and you know how what do
we do you know I kind of what are the
answers here and the urologist was very
was brilliant he's a brilliant
communicator and told us what the
options were and I said we just got to
get a plan you've got to get a plan
together because you need you need to
know what you're doing and and then
we'll be positive and we'll just kind of
keep being positive about it and
um and that's what we did really you
know once he got over the initial shock
we just really kind of focused on it as
a project that we had to to deal with
and um it's a bloody awful operation you
know you get in basically six stab
wounds in your torso and it is really
invasive and it's a horrible thing to
see him in you know the pain he was
afterwards it's a horrible thing to go
through but he's doing really really
well now and you know he's he just said
to me last night actually when we were
about to go to sleep he said he said
we've done really well haven't we
because he said people keep saying to me
like how are you all how's it you know
and he said we've done well I said we've
done well you know because he's he's
good the kids have been great throughout
it we've been through you know something
that kind of unifies you I think as a
family you know can really solidify you
as a family so
um we're very lucky
he's your like you know for throughout
this conversation I've really got a
sense that this person is your rock
totally
I was trying to think of a bigger
superlative than Rock but um yeah he is
he's um I remember once years ago doing
a podcast called walking the dog with um
Emily Dean and at the end of it she said
to me you've got Kenny itis I said sorry
she can't stop mentioning him and
he's just great
I'm very lucky
I knew I wasn't gonna lose him
but he's a great he's a great man and
I couldn't I couldn't ever
I couldn't have ever wished for anybody
to share my life with you know who's
better
I used to
and then when I was having my kind of
negative phase with men
um and I perhaps didn't think I deserved
somebody like Kenny
and
I'm glad that I decided I did because
you know time is everything isn't it and
when I met him if I'd been that person
before
I wouldn't have called him you know
because he would have been too too good
for me too nice for me and
yeah he's
he's been the most brilliant supporter
he's so positive he's so encouraging and
you know he just really believes in me
and gives me such enormous strength and
you know but he's also a vulnerable and
sensitive person you know he's he's so
um as a role model for our son you know
I feel like I've got this great person
who's alongside me
what what advice could you give me
because you know you've been in this
relationship with with Kenny I'm gonna
guess I'm gonna say 22 years 21 20 yeah
99 so yeah 20 coming up for um 24 years
24 when we met we met January 99.
[Music]
if you were to give me a piece of advice
on how my relationship could last for so
long
what would that advice be
I think it's
and we always and we don't always but we
often will have those conversations with
each other actually about why we are
still going strong and what it is that
because we've been through like normal
marriages you know we've been through
rough patches and periods where you're
kind of you know not never before we got
married you know it was but marriage and
children and the commitments they do
test you and they do put you in
positions where you feel uncomfortable
and this is not kind of what I expected
things to be and how and I think the one
thing is communication we always talk
those things through Kenny is very much
like you don't go to bed on a
disagreement or an argument you know you
sort sort sit down and discuss and
that's metaphorically you know it
doesn't have to be at bedtime but you
know you don't just let something Fester
he always says that he nips it in the
bud before it's a bud you know so if he
can see something's a problem and but
also it's okay to have disagreements you
know we have robust disagreements about
things we're not aligned on every single
thing because that's not real either
that and I think it's it's important to
know how to disagree
my parents sometimes had really
screaming rows when I was little and
that's really horrible to hear as a
child because you don't want that you
know and screaming around is a one thing
but actually being able to disagree is
is really important having your shared
kind of passions and goals in life and
things you want to do together is also
but also having your differences and
having your like you know his his things
that he likes to do separate to me is
really important because you can't live
in each other's pockets all the time so
I suppose those things I'm saying to you
through hindsight looking back I think
you know I wouldn't have sat out at the
beginning and said okay Kenny these are
the things that we have to and I was
talking to um we have to do I was
talking to somebody younger a lot
younger the other day about
relationships and the kind of young
people now and kind of how relationships
you know start is so different and how
relationships even come to be and
expectations of relationships and and
the the worry for me is that it's all
about perfection and it it's never going
to be perfect you know there are always
going to be things that go wrong but I
think if you're if you're into and
you're kind of aligned on on the really
important things the values that you
have then you can overcome you know
bumps in the road so and also you've got
to laugh you know having fun is really
really important so yeah I've always
I've always resisted talking too much
about Kenny because I've always felt
like I'm going to jinx it you know if I
say something but I feel now with nearly
a quarter of a century gone that we're
okay we're definitely not going to break
up tomorrow no yeah so I used to at the
beginning I always used to think I'm not
going to talk about it because you know
it's it feels too good I'm gonna you
know I'm gonna make it go wrong if I
talk about it so do you schedule Kenny
time I say this because I've been sort
of dealing with this recently where I'm
so busy with work and workers all
scheduled don't do anything that's not
scheduled is time with my partner so
that can sometimes Fall by the wayside
so and then you don't want it to feel
too formulaic do you yeah which is it
it's scheduling like what tab has she
got she read it's funny because I've sat
here with someone who said you should be
scheduling that time and then I can't
the prospect of going to my girlfriend
be like let me put few into the schedule
I think she would be very happy so I
wanted to figure out what what you do to
make sure you know you told me you're
doing the World Cup you've got all of
these incredible things coming up how do
you make sure is there a practical way
you make sure your relationship doesn't
fall by the wayside
I think we always have uh we're lucky
because most mornings you know we're
having breakfast together we're kind of
aware of what each other's days are we
have you know dinners and things
schedules and we've got things we might
do at the weekend so I think there are
weeks where we don't see a lot of each
other you know if if our schedules
aren't really aligning and but we know
it's okay because we'll pick up you know
pick up some time at the weekend or
something I think through our
relationship early on Kenny was away a
lot with his rugby and he'd be traveling
and then coming home and that was really
hard when you had weeks away from each
other
um but it did make I think you know
absence makes the heart grow fonder and
you really kind of want to be with that
person you know you want to be with that
person but I wouldn't so much schedule
it as just make sure that you've got
something nice coming up or you've got
something you're going to do together or
you know you've got an afternoon
yesterday I took a break for about half
an hour's back-to-back recording podcast
and it was a gorgeous day and I knew he
was outside he'd done something outside
so I just went out in the garden just
walked around with them for half an hour
because I knew he wanted to show me
things that he'd been doing and that
made didn't feel good showing me these
things so and it made me feel good as
well because I was getting a bit of
vitamin D and I was kind of having a
nice chat with him and I think
spontaneity actually is really important
in a relationship and not always you
know planning trying to be more
spontaneous in your personal life to
your yay business life you know you've
got to be you've got to be on it but I
think yeah the spontaneity is quite good
and he gets you know like he'll be like
oh are you coming to that you know if he
was doing something a charity event or
something or business sort of thing and
I said I'm going to come along to that
you know oh great it's great that you're
there and I really love it when he says
that because he wants me to be there you
know so
um I'll make the effort then to go along
to something or you know maybe even I've
even picked up golf again because he
loves golf I think right we're heading
into a period of our life we're gonna
have more time I can play golf again so
I've started playing golf again oh wow
you could teach me we have a closing
tradition on this podcast where the last
guest asks a question to the next guest
they don't know who they're asking it
for they just write it in this book and
I don't get to see the question until
open the book so the question that's
been left for you not knowing that it
was for you is
or interesting what would you do
if you absolutely weren't afraid
if I had no fear
I would when my kids have left home I
jump on a plane I go and try and work in
La for a year
like I'm working about I always wanted
to work in American TV so I would go
right I'm gonna just go bang on the
doors of execs and and if you could
write write the job role what would the
job role be in America
it would be pretty much Oprah Winfrey
yeah I think that if I had no fear
that's that's what I do
I could see you doing that in fact
that's that's been rattling around in
the back of my head for a long time when
you said earlier that you wanted your
own talk show I was like I could 100 see
that yeah you have all the attributes
you know even in your writing I see
I see that I see the huge potential of
like great conversation that openness
the vulnerability the way that you make
people feel calm
um and you create a bridge for them to
be open to
your elocution is that the word your
ability to articulate yourself in such a
wonderful apparently way with such ease
I could 100 see that oh wow thank you
I'm very excited to watch the show oh
thank you so much when I when I grew up
I wanted to be Oprah you know as a kid I
wanted to be Oprah and that was the
person I think that I thought wow that's
amazing but then of course you're in
this country and you look around and you
know kind of who are your role models
yeah yeah I got to meet her once um by
accident uh we were in a lovely
restaurant in London and she was dining
a few tables away and I would never go
up to somebody and you know do that
thing and I Kenny was going to me we
were with some other people who worked
in Telly they were kind of execs and
they everybody knew she was there you
know and Kenny said oh my God he knowing
she's my hero because he said Oprah's
there I know I know and uh he's saying
are you gonna I said no of course I'm
not and she just walked past the table
and he just got hold of her hand and she
looked down at him and he said and she
was so warm and he said I'm so sorry I
know you're leaving but I said my wife
absolutely adores you and she just got
hold of my hand and she put it on her
heart and she looked me in the eye and
said and I adore you
and I was like thank you she hadn't got
a clue who now we all were but she was
so warm and lovely and actually I said
to Kenny afterwards I hate you for doing
that but I love you because I have like
I have a I touched Oprah Winfrey's hand
and um yeah so um I think you know the
way she's created her her whole
broadcasting Empire as well is just
amazing she's such an incredible role
model and has a battle through you
imagine being at Winfrey at the
beginning of her career you know kind of
let alone you know she was an actress
but also what she'd gone through as a
child and then to forge her way as a
news broadcaster in in that environment
in America I think she is yeah she's
such a she's a good role model I think
yeah she's a role model to me too she's
a huge role model to me in so many ways
um her grace her class her struggle you
know exactly all the things you've
described there
um but so are you you're a role model to
me as well and that that became clearer
and clearer throughout your book and you
know I'm someone that's just stepped a
foot into the TV world over the last
like year or two with Dragons Den but
people like you that I've
um on my screen
um your skill there's a real skill to
what you do and I don't think it's it's
always appreciated to its full extent
the level of skill the research the
diligence the hard work the the talent
to do what you do
um is really astounding having been on
camera a little bit I really really
appreciate that and um I really also
appreciate you writing a book like this
because the vulnerability of this book
is going to
um unlock a lot for a lot of people it's
going to liberate them from a lot of
their own concerns and really also you
know I'm not someone that understands
menopause
but it's important that I do and the
lens that I I read about menopause
through isn't from an experience that I
might have someday but it's the the
women in my life that matter to me
that's so important and having empathy
for them yeah um and one of those is my
my mother and her own Journey um with
that and it gave me a huge sense of
empathy that I didn't have before a huge
understanding that I didn't have before
from Reading you you talk about that
um
in this book and so openly previously so
thank you because this is a very
important book that I think everybody
should read regardless of their age race
or gender
I think there's something really
important there for everybody and thank
you for coming here today and being so
open and honest with me it's a huge
honor to meet you it feels like every
you know I freak out a little bit when I
see people that I've I've looked up to
for so long on TV screens so yeah
absolutely overwhelmed by everything you
just said there so thank you so much
because you are obviously
just what you're doing at the age that
you've done you know is is phenomenal
and to to have that kind of wisdom to
you know to be able to read a book like
mine I feel like we're actually very
different in lots of ways but very
similar in other ways and so that really
means so much thank you and really
really appreciate that and best of luck
with all the incredible things that
you're doing too
thank you
[Music]